he said they didn't have to follow
blocking
and they didn't have to say the same
lines
you say it's a death to the actor's gift
to put their concentration on the effect
they're having on the audience because
they should have their concentration on
their acting partner
okay
so if I'm in a scene with you let's say
and it's opening night and I know my
parents are in the audience and high
school friends and I'm just oh I'm gonna
this is going to be great
but really that's the kiss of death for
the actor because I should be focusing
on our
scene our argument our
whatever it is that's
binding us up there
well that's the scene the scene is the
relationship
seen as the relationship or
relationships if there's more if the
scene there's more than two people in
the scene
um
yeah that is the scene
is the relationship and how it changes
the relationship starts out in one place
and it ends up in another place and and
the the process of it change of the
relationship changing that's the
emotional event
that for and and it can be very subtle
it can be very small that in the
beginning they're friends they're good
friends and at the end of the they've
during the uh and during the scene they
exchange intimacies and at the end
they're closer friends than they were at
the beginning
so that that's you know that could be
that could be a scene or that could be
an emotional event
um
but it has to happen in the moment and
the and the safest way for something to
happen in the moment is it is is to be
focused on the response of your partner
now doesn't mean you have to always be
in each other's eye line
you know that one character might be
making a sandwich and the other one is
over there so that you might not you
don't have to always have the the eye
line but but you have to always have the
awareness
of the uh of the other of the other
character the other actor even if it's a
single even if the even if it's a
close-up on uh on this on this factor
that that the other actor even if
they're out of frame they're still in
the scene so they're still
they're still in the shot even though if
they're not physically in the shot and
that is this the simplest way the
strongest way the most effective way the
most reliable way for an actor not to be
not to start worrying about whether
their parents are going to like it or
not is to uh or whether the director is
going to like it or not or whether
anything else is to is to be is to lose
themselves in the other in the other
actor
um
and you know and and connecting to the
other actor is the thing that that um
awakens an actor to their own impulses
it sounds con uh like a
counter-intuitive but it's true
so let's say we have actor a and actor B
on stage
and actor a is very much about playing
off of actor B and is dialed into them
and has been able to lose the audience
in some sense they don't even realize
they're there but actor B is concerned
with the audience and is concerned with
their performance and there's a
disconnect a can't connect to B Because
B is in its own performance yeah well
the director has to speak to actor B
uh what if
in that moment some people might you
know get it carried away and they run
with it and that actor a can't
have that director intervene it's
supposed to talk about a theater piece
could be a theater piece yeah so how
would Alex yeah I'm sorry the director
has much less control than the theater
piece so sure so that's a completely
different thing anyway because they're
you know once they open they start
making their you know they start
changing things so I mean I did it
myself when I was in theater you started
you start throwing out Direction left
and right but but for for film and most
of my people who who uh most of my
readers my book uh directing actors 25th
anniversary edition are film directors
or television and
um so yeah and the directory has a
tremendous amount of control
uh over over things so certainly over
whether to do another take or not
still hear about oh sorry but we do
still hear about an actor upstaging
another actor and kind of running with
it should actor a who's trying to stay
more true to the scene
play off that and some should they bring
that to the performance if B is running
wild and and is unharnessed and is like
wait a minute you're changing all the
rules here should a then say okay I
guess there's new rules here and I have
to go with it well that's that's a tough
one that did happen to me when I was
doing theater back in the 70s I was
doing this
play it was pretty strange play and uh
and one and it was like five people on
five or six people on stage at once and
sitting together five or six
female uh characters on stage at once
and we were we were blocked so that we
were sitting in a circle and then there
was one actor there who had the fewest
lines
and and she was playing an old lady and
so she she decided to
pretended you know she had dentures and
that her Dentures were loose
so
doing this kind of thing through the
whole play and my character was my
character was also a little bit of a
crazy person and but I kept my craziness
you know within the bounds of the
direction I'd been given and and the uh
you know and giving making sure that the
actors who are supposed to have Focus
had focus when they were when they were
supposed to have it and but but this one
lady was throwing everything off and uh
a toyed with the idea of picking up on
her energy and being as crazy as her in
order to feel like I was still in the
play but I decided not to so uh but
there were I had some friends who came
who said you know she's actually very
funny she's actually the best thing in
the play and so you should match her
energy and and uh and and go uh and go
ahead so I don't know it it's uh but you
know it's the the director was also in
the play
so she was there every night and
um I wanted to work with her again so I
didn't think she would like it so I
didn't do it but does that answer your
question is that what you meant yeah it
does I'm thinking actually uh was it
Robert Altman's uh come back to the five
and dime Jimmy Dean oh right so you have
Karen Black you have Cher you have all
these different people and they're all
their own star of the show but in
different ways and they don't really
seem to be outshining one another
they're they're contained within their
parts but when their part is up their
brilliant kind of thing
but not everybody works I'm sure who
knows how it was behind the scenes but
for the audience you see this
thing where no one's trying to step over
one another
right well Waltman was famous for his
ensembles you know that that and he when
you're asking how does the director set
the tone and and he always made sure
that every everything was at an ensemble
piece so that and and and everybody was
going to get their turn ah everybody was
going to get their turn and and you know
he promoted and created an all-for-one
and one for all atmosphere on the set by
giving huge amounts huge amounts of
permission I one of my students was in
um
uh the player I think and uh had a small
part in in one scene and and she told me
afterwards that he said he wanted them
to do it differently on every take
he said they didn't have to follow
blocking
and they didn't have to say the same
lines
and uh they can do whatever they could
follow any impulse and I mean it's a
brilliant movie right so so
um that was his way of doing it and and
um and he knew everything about blocking
he could block really really well you
know the player that opening scene it's
blocked within an inch of its life you
know in order to have that four minute
take everybody has to hit their marks at
exactly the right time so he knew how to
block a scene perfectly but he he could
see if it was there or not and he would
let the act I don't know but that's him
I I never tell my clients or my students
that they should do that you know try to
be Robert Altman he he's he was a genius
and
um but I think he'd let people know
you're gonna get your turn you're you
can uh you can trust me he they I mean
actors trusted Altman
completely
I think that you said the magic word
yeah get your words get your turn yeah
and so you feel like you don't need to
you know mess with the Dentures so to
speak even though you said that your
friend said that it worked but but I
could see that happening where maybe it
could take some people out of the play
and they felt distracted or who knows I
wasn't there but but I like that but you
know if if it's a movie of course you
you could just not use any close-ups of
that of that character it's it's very
easily fixed in the editing room just
don't use the don't use the shots that
she's in if you think she's gone too far